It's lunch time here at this kindergarten in Japan...
...and the children are eager to see what their parents have made for them.
In this country, a dry sandwich wrapped in tinfoil just won't do.
The packed lunch has been elevated to something near an art form.
On this table, there's some great ones.
Here's "Hello Kitty" and a teddy bear.
And right next to her friend, that's a piano.
It's great, isn't it?
Now, some people need a bit of help to learn how to make the perfect packed lunch,...
...the perfect "bento."
The lady who lives in this flat is an acknowledged expert.
Today, Tomomi Maruo is teaching her class of moms...
...how to make a cartoon character called "Totoro"...
...using rice and sesame seeds,...
...as well as a teddy bear's face out of fish cakes.
It's not easy for the students.
We have this idea of presentation, how it looks and precision.
So, I think that's part of this culture.
So, who are these, these portraits?
Michael Jackson.
That's Harrison Ford.
As in Indiana Jones?
With the Indiana Jones hat and stubble.
How did you do the stubble?
It's seaweeds, little seaweeds.
And do you do this kind of character bento every day?
That's very devoted.
It's fun.
I enjoy doing it and my kids enjoy it.
Back in the kindergarten, lunch is coming to a very noisy end.
None of it lasted very long,...
...the cute pandas, the colorful characters.
What took hours to make has been gobbled in a matter of minutes.